we are here today joined by a very
special guest please welcome Steven T
Seagle all right guys doing about you
welcome to collide of yours thanks so
much it's great to be here and you are
here for many reasons you have an
incredible body of work but specifically
you have a book called get naked what a
series of graphic essays which came out
last year but is nominated for two count
of two eyes are Awards it's pretty
exciting yeah yeah no I wanted to see if
essays could be comics I like lots of
different things I we talked just before
I started in the 80s doing like small
press black and white I've done x-men
have done you know image books vertigo
books I'm all over the place so I
thought how much more over the place can
I get
let's try essays and we did 19 travel
essays of different places I got naked
nobody wanted to see that but here is if
now any Debose for best both for best
humor publication and for best short
story for get naked in barcelona yeah I
don't know what made Barcelona so
special to be naked in but that was the
one I think it was the relatability of
the sports stuff except for COI I mean I
live line I gotta bring man you guys
gotta make choices but what I love about
the book is that it immediately like
page one naked like you there's no
warm-up there's no foreplay so to speak
you're like you're in and the book
instantly feels relatable that's the
exact we're gonna use everyone has one
or many stories they're like well I've
had that feeling when you were writing
it did you cite other people did you
have conversation like how did this book
to come together uh well that's a
complex question I mean first of all is
I don't think I was naked anywhere until
I was about thirty honestly I was a
scrawny kid I was you know told from a
young age people would put their hand
around my arms and be like I can touch
my fingers I'm like that doesn't seem
good so I just I literally I was cloaked
I was dressed for Handmaid's Tale in the
mail since before there was such thing I
didn't wear a short-sleeved shirts I
never wore shorts because job is I'm
just never going to be seen and then
when I turned 30 I developed this heart
condition and I had to start swimming
all the time when you swim one way or
another unless you can do that towel
Mambo that some people do it's gonna
come off and I was like oh what was I so
hung up about and then I started
traveling a lot and it just wound up is
the book points out naked in various
places and I thought
oh that's weird I don't kind of feel
freaked out about this anymore when did
that change happen and it didn't happen
in America was the answer so I wrote 19
essay is about 19 different countries
where they just kind of have different
feelings and vibes about us you know
it's just not a big thing anywhere
except the US for the most part and the
main answer your question is I wanted to
do essays like I love David Sedaris Lib
Spalding Gray like just performance
monologue II stuff and essay stuff but
I'd never seen it in comics quite that
way mm-hmm and about five years ago I
was thinking well what would an essay
look like in comics for him and I hate
comics they have too many words even
though a lot of mine do but I was like
well an essays gonna have even more and
how do you solve this problem and I
couldn't I just sat with Photoshop
moving stuff around trying to figure it
out never came up with a good solution
but I teach at a school in Vivah Denmark
called the animation workshop and those
students they have three majors comic
books
animation graphic computer graphics and
I teach the graphic novel course a bunch
and the students did a session with some
other teacher on journalistic comics and
they post them online I was like this
has a lot of text but it's still a comic
and I would read this so then I pitch
the school I'm like I want to do essays
can we just make it an assignment and if
it turns out really great we'll publish
it an image and if it doesn't turn out
great it was an assignment yes that's
exactly what it was like I think you'd
have to ask them but uh no the well the
weird thing was that it was get naked so
I knew it would be essays but I didn't
know what I have a lot of weird family
stories like my dad was mistaken for
Richard Nixon by the Secret Service and
carted away because they thought he was
the president not because he wasn't the
president and then he spoke and he's
from North Carolina's like I don't think
you got the right guy they're like right
tell those stories but then I thought
it's hard enough selling an essay I'm
definitely not gonna sell an essay about
my family per se I've either got to have
the word sex naked or gun in the title
to make an impact in the US and make a
gun was taken make a gun was taken so I
I was like I don't think I've ever been
naked and I'm started to think of all
these places I had been naked I was like
oh this is weird why why are there all
these stories so I wrote all 19 of those
and
read them all to the students the first
day Mike here they are find one that
speaks to your soul or that you can at
least stomach
you can draw me naked or not draw me
naked I'm not going to pose naked for
you but that's up to you and they each
pick the story that was they're all from
different countries too so some of them
picked a country they were from or
something to country they weren't from
and they just I said there are no rules
just make it not boring I'm gonna check
in with you everyday
page-a-day in ten days we're gonna knock
this book out and we did it in ten days
ten days and then we spent three and a
half months polishing it but literally
180 pages of that book were done in ten
days so you were working in like
nonfiction comics has become one of the
strongest areas have come yeah
but typically with folks like Joe Sacco
doing reportage or Lucy Knisley doing
memoir people are doing their own thing
I feel like it's only like Harvey Pekar
and others who have taken their sort of
autobiography and seen a bunch of
different people take it on what were
what was it like it's getting back
nineteen versions of your own life weird
first of all no one who drew me naked
drew me massively endowed and I was like
how did you know that so that was a
little sad I thought somebody would at
least you know try to get the a not
often my wife was like you do wait the
drawing wood it was it was it's always
weird I did another book for vertigo
called it's a bird which was
autobiographical semi won the Eisner
yeah and I was nominated but didn't win
it's a theme for me
I'm Susan Lucci but I'm comic books
Leonardo DiCaprio he did one for a while
that's right that's right
holding out oh the bear surely essays
will turn that around but that book was
about my family's history with
Huntington's disease and why it made me
not love superheroes in a weird way it's
also about how much I don't like
Superman and then DC published it
he knew thanks it was great but it was
that was for me that was the real dive
into the deep end because it was very
personal and even though abstracted
there were things that I had to say
about my family and my parents and my
brother and you know my aunt who died of
Huntington's disease that needed to be
kind of just truthful and I hadn't I
always infused myself in my work but not
literally
and so that was a challenge for me so
that this get naked seemed like ah
that's a walk in the park it's it's
awkward and embarrassing which I tell
the stories to anybody anyway and so it
didn't seem quite so shocking so I'd
like I'd like to do more until my Nixon
stories and whatever but I don't know
how much me the world needs in comics
you and I were talking right before air
about the evolution of digital versus
print and I feel like we've seen
especially in the last five years the
rise of books like this being an option
I don't know how long ago this would
have been a book that could have been
published and like we have been
discovered like what David Mack's doing
with art and like the way you're
reshaping what the narrative is how have
you felt being inside comics as we've
hit this new kind of digital Renaissance
where there's a lot of bold choices
being taken yeah well the first bold
choice kudos goes to image because I
published everything I do through image
now and I'll show up one day and be like
I want to do camp midnight for ten year
old girls and Erik's even since like do
it and I come back here later Mike I
want to do 19 essays about taking my
clothes off he's like do it and I think
that it's the willingness of publishers
to take that risk like it's a bird Paul
Levitz could have said he did say he's
like no more DC heroes and vertigo books
I'm like can I just do Superman for one
and he was like okay it takes it takes
that person who's willing to take the
risk and then the book has to be good as
good as you can make it and so those two
things I think comics is a medium and
you can tell any kind of story in comics
we hopefully know that by now but it's
the risk financially of will that comic
sell and if it doesn't will there be
another one like this is the first book
I've seen of essays if it doesn't get
out of the red then it will be the last
book we see of essays you know so it's
it's both of those things but I think
there are publishers usually willing to
go out on a limb if they believe in the
work and you've never been afraid of
experimenting and trying new things from
the biggest names to making your own
thing from scratch like a certain series
some of our folks at home I like can you
talk a little bit about moving between
those worlds and how you landed in
animation well yes oh man of action
which is my company with Joe Kelly Joe
Casey Duncan Rouleau three other comic
book nerds like myself started
accidentally it literally this is a
terrible story to tell but it started
because we were tired of walking around
San Diego comic-con
literally and so one of the one of the
Joe's may be Joe Kelly was like we
should get a booth and sit down and
watch it walk by us we're like well how
much is a booths and back then it was
400 bucks or something we're like it's a
hundred bucks ahead and then we don't
have to walk through this thing so we
literally filled the paperwork and then
they were like well what's the name of
your company we're like you don't have a
company and so Joe Kelly was like we're
called evil geniuses and they're like we
already have an evil geniuses right then
we're called man of action so we had
this booth and was man of action it was
just to literally buy comics and hide
them behind the table and sit down when
you retired and somebody walked up while
we were there the first year and they're
like man of action what do you do we're
like we're writers they're like oh do
you write short films and we're like
sure and so they hired us to write for
short films which only one got made but
one guy made the next year we sit down
again somebody's like man of action what
do you guys do we're like we write
comics and short films I like oh do you
do video games for like yes and they're
like okay you all wrote the x-men so
we're gonna hire you to write this x-men
video ok cool third year now here's the
worst part or the best the third year we
sit down and like man of action it was
Matt Senreich from Robot Chicken who's
nearby here somewhere he's like Matt
action you guys do cartoons right we're
like yes he's like oh good Cartoon
Network wants like a boys action show
and that's not really what we do but you
do that so go talk to them and we talk
to them and we sold them Ben 10 never
worked on a cartoon before none of us
so Internet sometimes buy the cart
before the horse and get the horse
that's incredible that x-men game was
like one of the notable best Marvel
games like it can be this good
like and that was just y'all being like
sure yes we do that we mean we wrote the
script for that which was like seven or
nine hundred pages or something
ridiculous and then Raven developed and
kind of did all the hard parts but we'd
all we had worked on x-men and the one
thing that unites all this stuff is
what's what's a good story and it's a
couple of things it's that you've got to
give the audience something you know not
just a bunch of plot details something
they got to leave with something so if
you read get naked I'm hoping you leave
with a sense that if you're like me in a
super self body phob you
get over that that's the moral of all of
those stories is there's awkward stuff
there's weird stuff but you can put your
mind at ease and just be yourself that's
possible so that's what I'm giving
people in exchange for their 25 bucks or
whatever that book costs with Ben 10
it's telling kids you know you don't
need ten different superpowers to get
through something you need to think you
know sometimes that's Quinn sometimes
Ben has an epiphany sometimes max tells
them but that's what unites those
stories so it's it's getting at what
what does somebody leave with as an
audience member what do you have to
offer the world and that's no different
if it's a video game a cartoon a comic
book and we'd all learned art learned
our chops that does a lot of a thing
learned our skill sets doing comics we I
honed our chops there's a chops metaphor
we're all eatin pork chops we're working
with writers and it's just kind of
applying that skillset there was stuff
we had to learn about cartoons that we
absolutely didn't know we've worked on
films and worked on TV shows you always
go oh this is different it's not just
writing I have to have a different
toolbox particularly funny memories of
making the the animation or film
transitions there well the the best
thing about the Ben 10 pitch was we're
four guys and we all have different
wildly different aesthetics and kind of
things that interests us and nobody
wanted to commit to the one thing we
could not decide what should we pitch so
we pitched 20 things in 20 minutes we
were like well it's too much but we'll
just take a stopwatch we'll have a bell
and we'll ring the bell at 60 seconds
and just move on to the next thing and
so idea eight was bent in but it was
literally like somebody would just start
a pitch ding boom move on to the next
one
so is the craziest pitch I think Cartoon
Network could ever the meta quality of
that being how Ben 10 happened they were
like there's something here well they
stopped us at 8 so number eight was this
they're like that's it that's what we
want and we're like no we're doing the
rest we worked hard on these things yes
we were a little indignant but then at
that same 21 of those with generator rex
one of those with Zack storm was now on
Netflix and there's 17 more which no one
is ever incredible is there any of those
other seventeen you can safely mention
because I'm fascinated by like what
they're know they're so boy
we still have a stop Washington Bell
somebody used to have the other 17
meetings what's in there now with this
brain trust of writers how is that how
is your shorthand evolved how is this
getting together in collaborating since
you've been doing it for so long has
anything changed a munch amongst you
folks Oh a lot yeah it's 19 years this
year that we've been doing man of action
gratulations
thanks it's it's hard to imagine it's
lasted that long and we're still
trucking along
yeah we've so we bring in a lot more
writers we have big writers rooms now we
have kind of 55 to 60 freelance writers
that we will use to staff a season of a
show and we bring in five or six of
those at a time
plus the four of us plus kind of our two
main principal full-time writer guys and
that lets us get a better mix than just
a bunch of white dudes sitting around so
that's been great we have learned to
streamline things so whoever is holding
the pen kind of is in charge of going
you talk you talk you talk what did you
say and then they get to make the
decision so we've learned to just lay
back and have ideas and let somebody
else coalesce the ideas but mostly it's
the reason it's lasted is because we all
know what's cool when we hear it we
don't always bring it the best idea and
you spit it out you're like that was
terrible but somebody else in the room
will go know that that thing you said
about the Bison let's stay on the Bison
and so we've learned to trust whoever's
feeling it to drive it and that seems to
be what works for us so comics was the
beginning how did you first like what
was the first comic remember picking up
what was your collecting process do you
still bag board and long box like what's
your comment I have had a midlife crisis
called my lights too which is the most
pretty comic book bag ever and that has
transformed well basically I don't see
you anymore I get home I'm like I'm
going to put these books in these new
bags but you could let me put my ugly
face in am i lied to and I'd look like
Brad Pitt it's this fear they have
changed my existence for the worse and
the better so I still collect comic
books mostly like old Silver Age
immortal and DC stuff I now I'm in the
fortunate place that all those books I
couldn't afford not even expensive books
like defenders seven I mean not like
crazy Golden Age stuff but I can get
those since there's fun to fill up these
runs I have no time to read them but
it's like yeah
I got this now what do I do this would
read them if you wanted to I do I have a
stack by my bed called
you know I hope I break my foot soon so
I'll be in this bed it can be all these
books but I just I don't get to most of
them I'm reading kill Raven right now
from the 7 knees and I started it in
January and I'm on like the seventh or
eighth issue that's how much spare time
I have I have a weird thing with Silver
Age where I don't like to read them
because they're from this like the paper
deteriorating so I don't read my
digital's that I own until I have the
print of the thing I own some now I have
access to my own books I'm the opposite
like I bought all that here's the nice
version of the library edition of Duda
I'm like now I wanna read the crappy
smell it to like the smell of Silver Age
books is so important yeah my first book
was Avengers 89 I've told this story
before but my mom and dad bought it for
me they were in the Air Force we were
moving a lot they were like this will
make you happy that we've moved again
and it scared the crap out of me it was
Captain marbles on the car we being
electrocuted and then there's creepy
aliens and stuff I was like do not give
me any more of these ever again I'm six
years old this is not for me and then I
took a big sabbatical until I was in
junior high and that's when I got back
into comics and now it's your life oh
it's my life yeah what do you prefer as
far as the like the mediums dude you
have a preference for you've you've done
so many things video games film is there
a certain way you think about them
differently is there a preference or
like mode and mood like right now you're
balancing between handling cartoons and
handling comic books is there something
you like is more relaxing than others
they're like a neutral the nice thing
about comics is the kind of comments I
do now where I work through image is me
and an artist going here's what we're
doing and image is not very aggressively
hands-on about you should do this
instead so it can be great in that I can
just have a vision I work with an artist
whatever we get collectively decided
that's we put out it can also turn out
badly because you know maybe I shouldn't
do 19 essays about taking my clothes off
there's no one to go don't do that so
you have to really self monitor a lot
but it's it's nice that it's this pure
if I could draw I would love that like
if I could just get an idea from my head
onto a page and I'm it
I love cartoonists like they can just do
it all themselves hallelujah but even to
people is not a lot as soon as you go to
a cartoon we're talking hundreds yeah
Lowe hundred
since we go to a TV show we're talking
two or three hundred so to go to a movie
we're talking four or five hundred if
it's a special-effects movie and I love
all that like it's it's all
collaborative but you just have to go
this is you and me making a comic this
is all of us making an animated show and
it has to be all of you it can't just be
even with a comic I can't write a script
and go draw exactly what I've given you
it has to be give and take you know you
have to go what do you want from a
script what do you want to draw I worked
with Kelly Jones once what love and he
was like I don't draw horses very well
I'm like we're doing horses
you can draw a lot of horses you should
because he should and then he loved it
okay yeah no it's it's part what does he
want it's part what does he need it's
part what do I want what do I need and
you've got a for the thing to be good
it's got to make you grow and if you're
just doing what you always do is that
why you've made so many twists and turns
it is it is a great part of that I try
to mess my creative process up every
year or two and not do it the way I used
to do it like a midnight books that I've
been doing with Jason katzenstein for
image another one's coming out in
October I always I start at the end and
I work backwards so I go here's what
it's about how do I get there
for Kampmann I start on page one with no
outline it was like I hope I make it by
the end of this book and it terrified me
but at the same time I made it and so
now on the second one I'm like I guess I
have to write this one that way too but
I won't write any other books that way
so I'm always trying to go how do i how
do I get it this differently I think my
toolbox is good good enough to mess
everything else up and hope I can
survive I'm doing a book with Teddy
right now where he's just painting
images they're all exactly the same size
and shape and I get them out of order
I don't know what he's painting but I
get to decide the sequence and then I
get to write the script and that's gonna
be the book so neither one of us knows
what we're working I love that that's
amazing yeah but it's terrifying but
it's that's what I need after 30 years
of doing comics so I got a terrify
myself has there been a moment like I
know the Breaking Bad writers wrote
themselves in the corners of the end of
Evo so it's that they had that moment of
like uh has there been a moment you've
written yourself into a corner or gotten
yourself stumped where you've had to
revamp enough that it reshaped the
entire book or the entire series well
not so much that because I can I write
backwards personally so it's more like
how do I start this as opposed to where
does this yeah have you not got in the
beginning
wide open like you can start an hour
before something happens or a day or a
year or a decade or a generation so it
is it's a question of how far back do
you go to get to this moment for a lot
of what I do but what I have done is
I've done a couple of comics projects
that for publishers going bankrupt or
you know the project leanness team are
losing an artist where the project dies
and then I come back to it decades later
and go oh I got to put this brain back
on and finish this thing or start it
depending on the ordinary things
so like Becky Cloonan and I did American
version for vertigo we just got the
rights back but vertigo cancelled it at
23 and it was for issue arcs we never
did issue 24 and everybody was furious
they're like why would you kill him or
like there was an issue 24 and I have an
outline for it but I didn't write it so
now I'm gonna go back and write that you
know I don't know how long it's been
like seven eight years or something
maybe ten and I have to put in that head
and go oh how did I think about this off
because I don't work that way anymore
so we said can we that's happening we're
gonna get the the ending to that series
at some point you know I don't even know
it's the ending you'll get the end of
that arc okay yes Becky and I are gonna
do it through image we're just trying to
find the time to get that issue done
sure
and then yeah my last question for you
because your world of comics is so
unique and a lot of times it's hard to
find like a gateway drug into comics you
had a scary experience in the beginning
but is there any book you'd recommend to
people that are trying to find their way
into non cape books journey is there any
gateway yeah right now I am so all about
my favorite thing as monsters
which was last year's I think it went a
bunch of eisenerz last year so not a
traditional comic book so not I I don't
even know what I thought it would be or
what I don't even know that I would have
found it and I think somebody forced it
on me and I I was like oh it's too many
words I don't think angry Scratchy art
and within about two pages I'm like I
should just quit comics because Neil
Ferriss knows what she's doing and I
have no idea what I'm doing so it's
about a you know it's about a young girl
who fancies herself a monster and that's
actually a really cool psychological
metaphor for stuff that's happening in
her bizarre part of the neighborhood and
her weird brother and her mom and murder
that may have happened upstairs and it's
thick it's like 300 pages and it's part
one so give me part two where are you
but it's it's a great book
alright so please you got to check out
the collection get naked it's up for
best location best short story yeah
thank you so much for being here thank
you you are and there will be a get
naked podcast soon yes oh they're all
being read out loud and animated with
the art so check that out when it shows
multimedia your home company has how
many different tiers how we roll baby
that's fascinating we didn't even have
time to get into the x-men or a little
thing called big hero 6 there is that
next time thank you it was great to be
here appreciate it cut thanks guys
until next week stay sweaty